in the wake of the Trayvon Martin
verdict in 2013 President Obama spoke of
his experience as a black man recounted
times when he was followed when shopping
in a department store when he heard the
locks on Carter's click as he crossed
the street when he was in an elevator
with a woman clutching her purse
nervously and holding her breath until
she had a chance to get off philosophers
like to ask big questions can we know
anything is there a god what is right or
wrong
like wise philosophers thinking about
race like to ask big questions what is
race
what is oppression should we strive for
a colorblind society our philosophical
thinking about race and social justice
tends to focus on large scale social
change on policies like affirmative
action yet we rarely reflect on on
interactions like those described by
President Obama these are the very
interactions that get in the way of
large-scale social change my approach is
distinctive and I focus on the micro
level on the level of day-to-day
interactions in my research I pour over
descriptions of the personal experience
both from mainstream media and those are
integrated in philosophical texts
imagine that you're in circumstances
like presidents Obama's you feel the
presence of the security personnel you
hear the locks click you sense the woman
clutching her purse there's a high level
of discomfort here of physical reality
to these experiences I analyzed these
and similar experiences using the
concept of bodily alienation and here's
what I have in mind when we perform
everyday tasks we our body's movements
sentries
seed from awareness for example when I'm
biking I don't need to focus on when to
push each petal these movements have
become second nature
however under oppressive circumstances
we tend to internalize the gaze the
presence of others and this can paralyze
us now what has been written about
bodily alienation about the structure of
these breakdown cases but comparatively
little has been written about what we
can do about situations like President
Obama's how can we change these types of
situations I adopted the concept of
embodied resistance in order to make
sense of our positive efforts embodied
resistance has been used by sociologists
and anthropologists to describe the
activism of members of oppressed groups
however in my research I apply embodied
resistance to activism of members of
both oppressed and non oppressed groups
in order to emphasize the continuity
between them I regard embodied
resistance as a result of our efforts to
mutually understand each other
to negotiate internal resistances and to
connect with others let's return to
elevator scenario so find yourself in
President Obama's shoes imagine now that
you're the woman clutching your purse
how could you change the situation
well you might decide to smile or even
touch the man but this is likely to
disturb him to reinforce the sense of
otherness members of oppressed groups
already have so how could you adopt a
sensitive gesture well here's where we
can draw on a long permanently Eastern
philosophical tradition of thinking
about the breath instead of reflexively
clutching your purse or overriding your
reflexes you might breathe and relax and
be able to respond in a more natural
manner you might smile or nod or even
start a conversation
think about how changes like these
could snowball into larger ones my point
is this we can perpetuate oppressive
climates or we can contribute to ending
them depending on how we use our bodies
my work consists in spelling out how we
can use our bodies in positive ways
where bodied beings and resisting
oppression begins with the body thank
you